bello aggiunti i ragazzi benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj e oggi torniamo
su un videogioco che ha segnato la mia
vita in meglio ci torniamo con una
persona che ha segnato la mia vita in
peggio però è vero io dico la verità
comunque sono con pietro ma siamo nella
modalità cooperativa di portal 2 porta
ad un gioco di ho adorato la vita ecc e
la modalità cooperativa che ai tempi
avevo fatto con dido pro non mi ricordo
una mazza quindi la farei con dietro ci
sei pietro ti odio che succeda sasso il
tuo partner scientifico consap ha
neanche 2 b2
ma cosa critichi nei 26 tu sei quello
gigante ci siamo noti sono detta che ci
sono anche io
eccoci c'è anche la cinematica in una
corte ragazzi quanti stanno assemblando
ecco quando sembravano tuo cervello e
non c'eri tu vinile eccolo chiesa di
quello fatto meglio sono io non so chi
dei due a prescindere ed ora che ti
toccano non vuoi farti toccare non
toccare o quello facciamo dillo che ti
piaceva ciao
ecco ci sono io cosa che bello che sei
fateci al vostro partner q a fare ciao
come si fa a non è questo ma sai come si
gioca a porta no ma tu non sai anche che
cos'è porta da ma tu sei il tutto è
scemo da lì avanti maledetto yacht che
penso che lo faccio tipo che hanno
portati così si è data entry anti
perfetto chi sei
ti ho aperto la porta aperitif
rivelativo bravo più o no devi aprire
mai di quella che mi ha fatto fare una
coppia custo ebete porca vacca che come
si fa adesso è così salita che hai fatto
gli passano grazie ciao grazie sentire
sei pronto stata sardo
se non era il convinto della mia idea è
vero
e invece e invece ha funzionato e faccio
io faceva stai tranquillo devo fare in
volo nel mentre che tu sei ok
in teoria ci dovrebbe essere un cubo che
dovremmo mettere nessuno però non ho ben
capito dove si dovrebbe trovare cercalo
forse proprio qualcosa e si però come lo
tiriamo mai tanto gli vai vai vai vai
vai vai vai vai perfetto
ora li schiaccia il pulsante schiaccia
il pulsante perfetto adesso ti faccio io
stessa cosa
porca vacca una spessa arrivando da solo
arriva no l'ho perso aveva facile facile
tranquillo e non mancano i portali ok ho
fatto per lui la madonna va bene ci
abbiamo fatto ok adesso come arrivo io
lo supero lo rifarà giro fammi vedere
che casino ma dopo diventa vomitare a
farlo non funziona ma sei un idiota
dai che palle devi farle fuori le cose
20 volte ok dai non fa non tocca ciao
amico entra muoviti che mi dà fastidio
se questo è la telecamera che deve
vedere che siamo in due
next ragazzi già per adesso siamo andati
nella tabella jean perde quando c'avevo
per questo
speriamo che mo a riguardo che sta
succedendo lì sapendo che se ci fai caso
di fare li mette prendi tu prendi il
apre ora ho capito aspetto afferma
faccio io ma porca vacca che schiaffo
rifai hai mai lo prendi al volo adesso
al volo al bano 6 schiaccia si riveli
fire i file schiaccia prima che primo
prima prima prima prima ora si sia
giusto no c'è casino raga le giostre
possono accompagnare solo perfetto aiuta
mica vi prego che toglie ai a e no devo
andar la giovane ala due fenomeni a gesù
è fighissimo però diventato frigo
bellissimo è certo 21 ma vera ma non ci
voglio credere
ma una volta si è riusciti a fare una
roba decente non ci posso credere che
sono riusciti a fare una roba noi due ma
ho la palla ma se ce l'avevo io la mamma
mamma mamma mamma ma che comunque deve
con questi così qui devi colpire le robe
servono per sparare il raggio se tu
dirigi verso quello che vuoi
no no no è un gioco della madonna aia il
karma il karma ok
aspetta aspetta ormai sono su cosa fare
qui la cosa dal santa dove a fare mamma
mia per due cervelli come noi è troppo
complicato sto gioco ho capito ho capito
sei tranquillo e di più che puoi tu che
puoi che puoi
ok speriamo
ha funzionato e ce l'ho fatta ci ha
fatto aperto ce l'ho fatta e viene
adesso o disattivato le trappole
mi sa che questa volta è un po più
articolata la faccenda amico l'italia è
vista questa volta un po più incasina
l'uno e lì è ok aspetta dai pon pon
questo fatto ok a dobbiamo essere
correva beh mica abbiamo essere
coordinate pur in questo tu vai nel 2
siamo
gesù e ora qua con questo che cosa ci
faccia ok melo portare indietro mamma
mia che casino si serve per il laser
malata dove puntuali bene ciò che a me
no a vendola presentando lo so posso
farlo se parlo soprattutto male sociale
veloce amico veloce o questo guardami
non farla partire non fa la patina fa la
partita ora partire un'acqua ok a timida
ma per vincere la vista del partner che
avete bisogno di tool che figata
temo che cariche che devo vaio ah ok per
poi sparare un portarli fuori che mi
porti anche meno ecco quindi li devi
mettere un portale l'altro lo devi
mettere da qualche parte devo puntare io
lo chiamo io l'ho punto io davo ma non
posso kagami può aspettare è proprio
così
aspetta aspetta minutoli davis tenendola
ferma zitto faccio io faccio aspetta ok
ok torna indietro tonie trovare intorno
e troveremo la che cosa ci sono.il porte
bravo li fallo fallo bravo e l'altro c'è
il raggio adesso poi così fa
vai vai tu non ti preoccupare è aperto
no secondo no devi cambiare non di
cambiare niente di cambiare il portale
più basso più basso di cederlo a meno
che non sia questo il problema
ah ok così lol rifatto lol scusa allora
dovresti farmi tu il cuore non lo so
come hai fatto arrivare all'evento e
metterne 11 c'è l'azzurro è uno sotto
sotto che se sei stato colpito dalle
cose poi salta mai ok perfetto due geni
e incredibili ma son presi che la cina
che ci da questo uno due tre
mica siamo riusciti ad aprirla porta
insieme non ci posso che il mio cervello
si è spinto oltre normalmente non faccio
questi ragionamenti cioè sono youtube
per non potete pretendere va beh direi
che siamo arrivati alla stanza scuola
non ai dati tonalità di dove siamo in
realtà sono stanza insert disco ci
dev'essere un disco da qualche parte
eccolo cdt gigi d'alessio va ai ragazzi
continueremo nel prossimo episodio
perché adesso basta in senso cioè le
meningi che sono esplose dove sia
piaciuto ragazzi come argomento mi piace
anche a vari social con il totale
descrizione non sapete ci vediamo al
prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]